hello Danny
you
oh my god they actually showed off some
iron fist so let's break it down it's so
glad to see that Loras Tyrell is still
alive somewhere in the Marvel Universe
so what's going on here is they're just
giving you a taste of his backstory and
his abilities like he punches the wall
out smiles a little bit so clearly this
is after he's been to Kunlun and has
come back so young Danny Rand goes down
in a plane crash finds the mystic city
of Kunlun or is found by those people
and this is where the Marvel Netflix
stuff like really starts jumping into
Thor territory in terms of mythology so
I don't know how they're going to change
this on the TV show or if it's going to
be straight-up from the comics they've
been relatively faithful with the other
stuff so the mystic city of Kunlun is
actually like this pocket dimension so
they like they might weave that in with
the backstory of the chased in the hand
just because the hand seems like it's
going to be the big villain for the
defenders team-up series and because
that gets into really mystical territory
naturally iron fist is the best place to
set that up just because the nature of
his powers so there are a couple big
ideas for the iron fist character you
may have seen some of the promotional
material so Rand Meacham is the law firm
that jeryn hogarth from Jessica Jones
works for she's one of the attorneys for
Danny rands family so if you didn't know
it like Danny Rand in the context the
Marvel Universe is one of these really
wealthy people he's kind of the Tony
Stark of the defenders in that way they
need money for some cool toys he's the
one that daredevil would go to so
everybody knows Danny Rand becomes iron
fist but what you didn't know is the
Danny's father the person who started
their big business with Harold Meacham
his business partner had actually been
to this mystic city of Kunlun before he
discovered it as a boy then came back to
the world developed this big business
had this family eventually he tried to
go back to the mystic city but ended up
dying in an accident
he was betrayed by his business partner
but Danny ran survived proved a very apt
pupil then came back and eventually
sought revenge on Harold Meacham for his
betrayal so they'll probably be shades
of that revenge story in the Iron Fist
series there's that voice in the trailer
that says hello Daniel that's probably
Harold Meacham this is actually the
actor that they cast to play him you
probably recognize him from the Lord of
the Rings trilogy like oh you didn't
I all those years ago as a boy and
you're back and you learned that I'm
somewhat responsible for the death of
your family but but obviously it gets
much bigger than that
and then you have Heroes for Hire this
is actually where it gets really fun and
they just become this crime-fighting duo
misty Knight is a part of it so I'm
expecting a lot of crossover with luke
cage's series in the way that Luke Cage
is very connected to Jessica Jones so
who is the big villain of the Iron Fist
series do you ask
well because Madame GAO's heroin I think
it was heroin that she's dealing has the
steel serpent symbol on it so I'm
expecting that of gout to be like this
larger ethereal villain in the sense of
iron fist and I'm hoping that the steel
serpent himself will be an actual
villain during the series because he's
kind of like the dark version of iron
fist so when Danny ran was learning
about the mystic arts he apprenticed to
this person that person also had another
son who coveted the power of iron fist
so naturally when Danny ran received it
he was very jealous and then sought Iron
Fist out tried to kill him to take his
power from him so because most of these
Netflix series are central to New York I
think The Herald Meechum revenge story
will be a bigger thing like you know
like Danny Rand left to die survives
comes back with all this power very easy
to follow revenge arc but it you know
obviously then he finds out about the
larger war between the hand and the
chaste finds a greater purpose you have
the presence of stick I don't know if
stick is going to crossover but what I'm
expecting is is you know because the
hand crosses over with the daredevil
comics I'm expecting them to blend a lot
of the daredevil mythology with the Iron
Fist mythology so we'll see how they
weave the Kunlun in with the idea of the
chased in the hand but when you watch
daredevil season 2 stick kind of implies
that he's this very famous person called
the chased and that's why the order is
called the chased so is he a man or see
this mystic figure who's lived for a
thousand years like it you just made to
question those things like they wanted
to feel very real but as we've gotten on
in the narrative especially with
daredevil season 2 things are pushing
into this very mystical territory so
it's a lot like the idea blending the
Avengers with a Thor mythology like you
have your standard superhero fare like
daredevil street-level hero then you
have your fantasy elements like Danny
rands power so I'll be really interested
to see the way that they weave that in
really cool stuff for his powers though
so he harnesses the power of Chi he
learned that but he also like in
addition to that he gains superhuman
ability
by plunging his hands into the molten
heart of a dragon absorbing its energy
so I don't know how they're gonna leave
that part in it's a lot easier for them
to explain his powers as him just
harnessing his cheat like it doesn't
require a lot of special effects like he
can harness focus his Chi to heal
himself faster he has enhanced abilities
like in the way Captain America has
enhanced abilities like he's a natural
human who's had his biology turned up to
11 so iron fist can do that but he uses
his Chi to achieve that state and he can
also telepathically communicate with
other people they might leave that into
the series the only thing I'm certain
about is the chief stuff just because it
plays really well with the way they
portrayed the rest of this Netflix
universe they don't really show her in
the trailer here but like you know like
I said jeryn hogarth is gonna be really
important for the series and Colleen
Wing you may remember Jessica Henrik
from Game of Thrones Nymeria Sanaa Game
of Thrones she was Jessica papa
during Star Wars she was one of the
x-wing fighter pilots during Star Wars
The Force awakens
so she's this martial arts badass so
expect her to be Palin around with iron
fist like helping him out in the way
that Missy Knight will help Luke Cage I
like there is a romance between Colleen
wing in Danny Rand so because this is
going to be dropping til the spring of
next year I wouldn't expect like another
really big trailer until Luke Cage drops
in September and I am expecting Danny
ran to appear somewhere in Luke Cage
like there will be other defenders
appearing in Luke ages series but we
really don't know exactly how that's
going to go down so let me know in the
comments what do you guys think about
iron fist obviously this is just a very
short trailer it's just meant to give
you an idea for his backstory what his
abilities will look like on screen just
like in punching through the wall here
you can see it's a much more martial
arts driven take on what Captain
America's abilities are just a normal
guy who's had his abilities turned up to
11 and who is a martial arts badass but
the Marvel giveaway still going on and
because it's been a couple days I'll go
ahead and name a new winner now so
congratulations Jonathan Edwards you win
a $20 Amazon gift card just be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I get your contact details
it's just a $20 Amazon gift card so I'll
start a new round now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video there will be a
whole lot of Marvel stuff happening on
Saturday
that's when all the movie panels are
happening so tonight is going to be Game
of Thrones and walking
so I'll be posting updates on Twitter
and Facebook on when those videos are
going to post so Comic Con hype train
continues happy comic-con day - so why
you guys wait for my next video to post
you can click here for my defenders
break to like my big team up trailer
breakdown and you can click here for my
Luke Cage trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight